>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Pam Jackson: So, I'm
Pam Jackson, I'm director
for the Center for the Book
here at the Library of Congress.
We are part of the library's
newly created national
and international outreach
unit and I welcome you
and thank you for being here.
To our partners and colleagues
cosponsoring today's events,
to the program participants and
to our speakers, to collectors,
to friends, to each of
you tonight thank you
for joining us, thank you
for giving us your attention
and being generous with us.
The library's central mission is
to provide the American people
with a rich, diverse,
enduring source of knowledge,
one that can be relied
upon to inform and inspire
and engage people to
support their intellectual
and creative endeavors.
And a part of our vision
here at the library is
that we are the chief steward
of the record of knowledge
for America and thus the world,
creating a springboard
to the future.
It's a future that I hope to be
one of compassion and courage
and industry and excitement
and remarkable accomplishment
and achievement, and one of
tolerance and acceptance.
And so, today's collectors
in their own rights are part
of our goal and hope and
desire for stewards of records
of knowledge and I applaud
you in your commitment
and you celebrate
the accomplishments
that will be shared tonight.
Here, at the Center for the
Book, which includes the Poetry
and Literature Center and the
Young Readers Center we promote
books and libraries,
literacy and reading,
poetry and literature because
we believe beyond a shadow
of a doubt is the best way to
empowerment, to enlightenment,
to educate and inform societies,
to protect and uphold democracy.
We believe more than
anything else books
and reading are the best
weapons against ignorance
and intolerance and we thank you
for being part of our mission
of service and fulfilling on
the promotion of knowledge
and the inspiration
that books bring us.
It's my job and my honor to
introduce our next speaker
in the program John
Cole, John Y. Cole.
Historian of the
Library of Congress,
more importantly the founding
director of the Center
for the Book which is
celebrating its 40th year
in existence next year.
With just the deepest gratitude
John for you and your role here
at the library what you've
created and what's to come,
thank you for creating
this event tonight
and for leading us
the way forward.
Welcome John Y. Cole.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Thank you Pam.
As you can see, I'm still
easing my way out of the Center
for the Book, but very
excited about being the Library
of Congress' first historian.
And one of the things I
can record is the success
of a program such as this one
of which has been transferred
to the Library of
Congress in recent times.
I want to say just a quick
word about this awards program.
In 2005, the magazine Fine Books
and Collections started this
program and competition to honor
and to award student
book collectors
and they went along very
well, but eventually some
of the other people in the
book world, including people
who are eager to become involved
agreed that we would take
over in a new partnership
the sponsorship
of the awards program for
certain here at the Library
of Congress, but also with other
partners the administration
of the program.
And our purpose always has been
to kind of broaden the reach
and to get more schools
and more students
and more people involved
in book collecting.
The purpose really is to
honor young collectors
which we're doing tonight
and kind of push them gently
and maybe not so gently into
becoming lifetime book lovers
and accomplished collectors
and even bibliophiles
if they aren't careful.
So that's one of the ways
that we are bringing
several groups together
for the sponsorship of this.
If you look at your program
which you may have missed
the other sponsors are the
Antiquarian Booksellers
Association of America,
the Rare Book and Special
Collections Division
of the Library of
Congress, the Fellowship
of American Bibliophilic
Societies, and the Grolier Club
and we are very grateful
to all of them and also
to the contributors
and supporters
and friends who've made
financial contributions
at various levels
to this program.
We hope that you like it, we
hope you continue to support it
and we promise that
we will continue
to bring you very
high-quality winners
which we are doing tonight
and I think you will enjoy
meeting them and learning
about what they are able to
think about as collectors,
it's really quite amazing.
I would like to welcome
the Grolier Club
as our latest partner
in this partnership
and president Scott Clemons
is here and Scott would
like to say a few words.
Scott. There you are.
>> Scott Clemons: Here I am.
Thank you, John.
I just -- the Grolier Club,
how many of you know
of the Grolier Club?
Oh, this warms my
heart to see this,
thank you that makes
my day to see that.
The Grolier Club was founded
in 1884 originally as a club
for private collectors of books
and since then it's
broadened a great deal
to include institutional
collectors as well.
Anyone tangibly involved
in the book arts,
so there are bookmakers,
there are typographers,
there are still a healthy dose
of private collectors
such as myself.
So, as sponsors of this award
it just makes all the sense
in the world for the club
to meet collectors early on
and introduce them to the
resources the club has to offer,
most of which are people who
have been in this passion for 10
or 30 or 50 or 60 or
more years as collectors.
So, one of the things
that we did last year
and that we're doing again this
year is that we are to each
of the four honorees
offering a year's membership
in the Grolier Club with all the
rights thereunto appertaining
as the lawyers would say.
And we hope to see
those people at the club
and the various events
that the club does,
including quite a
few here in DC.
There are number of club
members in the greater DC area.
We do three or four events a
year here in DC and nationwide,
and increasingly even
worldwide as well.
And as a matter fact I would
invite all of you to come
to the Grolier Club in spite
of being a private club
on 60th Street in
Manhattan it is also open
to the public six days
a week with exhibitions
and two different galleries,
public lecture series,
a research library.
So, stop by and when
you do ask for me
and if I'm there I'll
say hello to you.
So, thank you again for
letting us be a part of this
and it's a privilege for
us to be a part of this
and thank you John as well.
>> John Cole: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Scott Clemons: Thanks.
>> John Cole: And tonight,
I'd like to offer a special
thank you to ABAA and especially
to Susan Benny who has carried
the administrative burden
for this contest and has
kept everyone in line
and has had many wonderful
ideas that we do our best
to incorporate, don't we Susan?
And we talk about other
ideas and it's interesting
that with the Grolier Club
of course there's a concern
about young collectors, with our
organizations there's a concern
about young collectors and this
is an alliance I think that all
of us involved in
are working on.
The other partner
within the Library
of Congress is the Rare Book
and Special Collections Division
and at this time I'd like to
introduce Mark Dimunation.
Mark is the judge on the part
of the Library of Congress,
but Mark is more than that.
Mark also is part of the
package that winners get
when they arrive here and
get a program this afternoon,
it was held at the Rare Book
and Special Collections Division
having Mark talk about a few
of the treasures, we have a
few books and things based
on collecting and
Mark does that so well
and I know everyone
there appreciates it.
I'd ask Mark to say a word
or two before we move ahead
with our speaker about the
process of judging and come
on Mark you can cover it
up pretty well, come on.
Let's give Mark a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation: Thank you.
imagine the terrified
look on their faces
when they're informed
I'm part of the package.
Welcome everybody, it's a
lovely event and for those of us
in the rare book in the
world this is always exciting
because we know we're looking
at the future of collections
across America, whether they
land in Goucher or the Library
of Congress so that
we're still talking.
I want to give you a sense of
what it's like to participate
on the end of actually
reading a variety of essays
from young collectors
who are talking
about the reasons
behind why they collect,
how they collected, what
prompted them to begin.
For those of us who live
with rare book collections
of course this is
the story we tell
of almost everything we
have in the division,
so it's a very familiar
tale to be told.
But I just want to give you a
sense of what we were coping
with just in the spirit of
the four prizewinners today.
Imagine if you will
in the reading of more
than a dozen essays that
include lists of books.
These are the people
who have filtered
through their local
competitions, that have come
to a national competition,
that have then been sifted
through to a final
round and that's
when the final judges
step in to read.
There are other people in the
room here who are participating
in this conversation
and they can back me up.
It's kind of a wild ride
that we go on in part
because we're confronting
in some cases materials
that we're very familiar
with and we want
to see the particular
take of the collector.
In other cases, as is the case
with the first-place
prizewinner, we were introduced
to someone we've never heard of.
And so, we're introduced
to not only the topic
but also the notion
of collecting
for the first time afresh.
So, in the range
of the conversations
imagine making a decision
between the collection of a
particular individual who comes
from Mobile along the southern
coast compared to a collection
on Sacco and Vanzetti and
finally, to the stories
of resistance during Jewish
resistance during the Holocaust,
and then finally a collection
of sailboats from somebody
who lives in New Mexico.
And to try and wrap your head
around these what it means is
diving deep into these essays,
which are extremely important to
the understanding and I think,
I suspect may actually be
helpful to the young collectors
as they're being
asked to explain maybe
for the first time what started
them and why they collect now.
So, Megan who collected the
Sacco and Vanzetti books talks
about her first introduction
to the trial and then sort
of running into conflicting
information and the bother
that that creates for her
and the effort to sort
of set the story right.
Whereas, Micaela who's writing
about Jewish resistance
during the Holocaust,
discovering that there's a great
deal of material from the period
but not so much about
resistance and the need
to keep that story alive.
Until we get to Luke's
story about Eugene Walter,
king of the monkeys which I
have to confess I kind of moaned
when I read the title I thought
he's collecting a naturalist.
Well, it couldn't be
further from the truth.
Eugene Walter is an
amazing individual
and we had quite a ride
and ultimately Luke's collection
landed in first place,
not just because of the
nature of Mr. Walter himself
who affiliated himself from
anything from Peggy Guggenheim
to the film Innovate and a Half
to writing cookbooks to talking
about Alabama to going back and
forth to writing about his life,
one book of which is
called the Untidy Pilgrim.
It's an amazing ride
of an individual
and you'll hear more
about that later.
So, it's a difficult
decision to be made,
this is how we make
that judgment.
How true to the topic and
to the goal and the mission
of their collecting are
these collectors and that's
when the prizewinners very
quickly sort themselves
out from the other contributors,
all of whom are writing
about interesting collections.
But what we find in the four
that have been given awards
today is a real passion not just
for the subject, but
also for collecting.
And it's the combination of
the two, of adding some sort
of material reality to
the interest of the topic
that they're writing about
that makes them true collectors
in the minds of those
of us who live
with these on a daily basis.
These are very erudite
essays in many cases
and I can say this an old
man now, it makes one proud
of the next generation who
are writing in full sentences
about books and that
just warms my heart.
It was lovely to have three
of the four here today to talk
about slightly more
polished collectors in a way,
giving them a sense of the
family that they've joined
as collectors and the
continuity in the world of books
of people seeking out books
because they love them
as things, because they
love them as ideas,
because they love them as
something that's come to us
from another person and the
stories that they reveal.
So, imagine for a moment,
sitting on the phone
with several individuals
staking your claim
around a particular topic
and you have a sense
of what it must be like to be
a judge in this competition.
So, congratulations
to everybody.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well as Mark
hinted, one person cannot be
with us today and we're sorry.
The essay prize winner
Samantha Flitter
from Princeton University
she wrote her essay
and Mark referred to it,
the Sand and the Sea and Age
of Sail Library, Sail Libraries,
reading about sailboats
in rural New Mexico.
So, she had quite a story
and wrote about it very well
and I'm sorry she
isn't here tonight,
but she was unable to make it.
However, it's my pleasure now
to introduce an individual
who besides loving books
and quite obviously food,
which we will hear much more
about is also an award-winning
author, a journalist, a teacher
and a community activist.
Toni Tipton-Martin is a very
busy person building a healthier
community for all of us
through her books, her teaching
and classes and now
her own foundation.
She has been invited twice
by First Lady Michelle Obama
to the White House
for her outreach
to help families live
happier and healthier lives.
And she received the 2014
Southern Foodways Alliance John
Egerton prize for this work.
With the Egerton
prize's seed money
over the past June
16th weekend in Austin,
Texas Toni hosted Soul Summit,
a conversation about race,
identity, power and food.
It was and sounds like it
must've been an unprecedented
three-day meeting.
Among her other activities
and honors Toni is the author
of the Jemima Code,
two centuries
of African-American
cookbooks published last year
by the University
of Texas Press.
It's an award-winning
bibliography and too late
for this listing,
but with the cards
from the winter here
are a couple
of other acknowledgments
of this book.
Here's one of the reviews, the
New York Times book review,
Jemima code is no ordinary
book, it's a heaping helping,
a long-overdue acknowledgment.
From NPR's Best Books of 2005,
it is a rare coffee table book
that serves up important
history and compelling imagery
and digestible bite-size chunks.
You can see there's a big
opportunity there for similes
and many other things.
I'm not going to talk
about her collection,
she's going to talk a
little bit about it I think
in relation with the book.
But the Jemima Code is
also the title of her blog
and a traveling exhibit which
features larger-than-life images
of black cooks at work taken
from Toni's gallery of authors
which she will tell us about.
In 1991, she was the first
African-American woman
to hold the position
of food editor
at a major daily
American newspaper,
the Cleveland Plain Dealer.
She's been a guest instructor
at Whole Foods Culinary Center
and appeared on cooking
channels, Foodography
and the PBS feature Juneteenth
There it is Again Jamboree.
Toni, I'm exhausted, help
get me out of this jam.
Here is Toni Tipton-Martin.
[ Applause ]
>> Toni Tipton-Martin: Thank
you so much, thank you.
Hi. So ordinarily speakers you
know we begin with what an honor
and a privilege it is
to be here but really,
I have to say I am a
little silly giddy,
I'm so excited to be here.
This is the place where
my work in some ways began
and so the ability to read the
winning essays as a journalist
and a reporter, as
an amateur collector
and to read your passion
and to see some of myself
in your writing it
makes me emotional,
it was just really a privilege
and it is a privilege
to be here.
So, thank you so
much for having me.
I've passed around a copy of the
card, not because I'm so vain
that I want you to see the
back with all of the awards,
my publisher did that.
But I'd like to begin really
the way that I begin everywhere.
This is the first opportunity
that I've had to speak
in a new family, a
family of collectors,
a family that is making me
feel a bit of confidence
about what I've just
experienced.
I speak to so many groups,
food people primarily,
but I will be speaking at
Duke for example next week
and so there are always people
that have a different kind
of an interest in my
material than people
who are not necessarily focused
on African-American history
or Foodways studies,
but as collectors.
And so, what I've given is
the card that I'm traveling
around with and I ask everybody
to take a minute to
look at the cover.
This is the cover of the book.
This is the book, but it doesn't
have the dust jacket on it.
So, this is the dust jacket that
would be there, how about that?
Take a peek and now
just for a moment notice
that you're having a
reaction to the cover.
It's a little easier when it's
a slide or when it's bigger,
but each of us individually
is having a reaction
to this picture.
Whether you recognize
the image as a woman
who might've been a caretaker in
your community, in your family.
There might be a sense
of pride connected
to memories associated
with this woman.
There might even be a sense
of shame for some people
that I speak to regarding
this image.
Whether that is
African-Americans
or white people we
all have a reaction.
And there's even a
reaction by young people
who don't have any idea who
she is and what I'm talking
about because you see packages
with faces on them all the time.
But the reason I ask
everyone to take a moment is
that in our daily busy lives we
go through life having reactions
to things and we're not
always aware of them.
We're being spoken to a lot
now about mindfulness right,
everybody's talking about being
mindful and paying attention.
And so, my work centers
on using food as a tool
for racial reconciliation,
that's my primary purpose.
It's why I won the Egerton prize
and other great things
that have happened.
And prejudice occurs one
affront at a time and so my goal
with writing the
Jemima Code was the hope
that we could restore an
image that has been used
in multiple ways to
distract us, to divide us,
to degrade one population
and use that image in a way
that by the time
you get to the end
of my work we're all
in the same place.
So even though we might start
somewhere differently we will
all wind up in the same place.
So, I won't even ask how many of
you have seen the Jemima Code.
But the Jemima Code
is a bibliography,
an annotated bibliography
and it is the story
of my rare black
book collection.
I'm an amateur accidental
collector,
I collected these books
as a reporter on a story.
My goal in writing this
book as I've said was
to describe each one of
these authors in a unique
and unbiased way so that by
the time we get to the end
of the book we're all
in the same place.
If you can't see it in the back,
there's a little black girl
and a little white girl
and they're going
off into the sunset.
And this is an image taken from
one of the books from 1978.
Two authors got together, a
white woman and a black woman
in Louisiana and
they published a book
with the same motive
that I have.
I just love that.
So, I'm going to save one of
these pages because when I look
for it when speaking
I always lose it.
So, as I said, I
was a journalist
in pursuit of a story.
I was the nutrition writer
for the Los Angeles Times many
years ago, some 30 years ago
and I was busy organizing
the cookbooks and working
with the recipes in the
collections, in the archives
in the department and I noticed
that there were no
African-American
cookbooks there.
But not only did I notice
there were no cookbooks there I
noticed that those references
to African-Americans were
usually very disparaging.
They made reference to
this Aunt Jemima character,
a mythological figure that has
lingered in American history,
southern history, in
literature, in film.
You will recognize her as the
nanny figure in many of the --
in everywhere right
in Southern history.
And I was looking for my
grandmother on the pages
of Southern history and I
wasn't able to find her there
and certainly not in the way
that I would recognize her.
And so, I had this idea
that I would interview
elderly African-American women
about their true-life
experiences
and hopefully be able to share
with the rest of the world,
the passion and the intelligence
and the knowledge and the wisdom
that I experienced in my own
community through these women.
And I told a couple of
people that I had that idea
and other books came out.
I'm not from the South I'm from
Los Angeles, so I told people
for example that I was
going to do this book
by traveling the South and
going to black churches
and that's how I would
find these women.
And lo and behold somebody came
out with a book on black recipes
from black churches
in the South.
So, I learned to keep my
idea about my next book very,
very close to the best.
As a matter fact, so many of
my friends who are scholars
who once this book finally came
out I received so many e-mails
from people saying we had
no idea what you were doing.
They knew I was working on
something, but not something
at this level of beauty.
So anyway, I was
there at the Times
and I thought I would
interview all these women
and then I realized I didn't
have really any access
to women in the South.
And one day there was a little
book, it's the one on the bottom
if you can see in the back, it's
called the New Orleans Cookbook
by Lena Richard, it
was published in 1985
and this is a paperback
edition of this book.
It appeared in a book
giveaway, at the Times
as reporters we weren't allowed
to take anything for free
and so we would give away books
that came in as review copies
so that others could
share in those readings.
And so, this book,
Lena Richard's book
showed up in this pile.
And so, I didn't quite know
what I was going to do with it,
there was no photograph
of the woman in there,
but it was called New Orleans
and even though I know Southern
food and Creole food are very,
very different I thought well
it might help me in some way.
So, I took this book home, I
put it on my shelf with all
of my other cookbooks and it
sat there for quite a number
of years, probably
about 10 years.
And then I was attending
an event in Atlanta
and John Egerton whose name,
in whose name the award
that I received was given was
a Southern sage civil rights
writer, a very important man
in the writings of the South.
And he had just returned from a
visit to the Library of Congress
and I heard him speak
and he spoke eloquently
about the women in my community.
He spoke about African-American
women and their contributions
to American society in
particular through food.
And I was astounded, I hadn't
heard anyone speak that way.
And so, I ran over to the
groupie gaggle that was hanging
around him, I had
no idea who he was,
but obviously everyone else did.
And I had shared that with
him that I had no idea,
I'd never heard anyone
speak that way.
And he said I've just returned
from the Library of Congress
and I have something in
my briefcase for you,
meet me in the press room.
And so, I waited for him in
the lobby of the press room
of the hotel and he went
through his briefcase
and he had this disheveled stack
of wrinkled pages from a book
from 1912 called the Kentucky
Cookbook by a colored woman.
He said he didn't know what
he was supposed to do with it,
but obviously it was intended
for me and so he gave me
that copy of the book.
I have to go by year to find it.
So, I had this stack of papers
and again I wasn't entirely sure
what I wanted to do with it.
But gradually I started thinking
more and more about cookbooks
as a mechanism for
telling a story.
I still didn't realize
that they could be a tool
that would change social
history and improve the status
and the perception of an
entire group of people.
I really was still just in
pursuit of my own story.
So, another couple of
years go by and now Egerton
and I are talking
about other content
and I encounter a book
called the Bluegrass Cookbook
and it was published in 1904 by
a white woman named Minnie Fox
and her brother John C. Fox
was a writer for the Atlantic.
And they published this book and
again as John Egerton had done,
they gave credit to these
African-American women
and they did that with images.
So not only did they attribute
recipes to these people in a way
that was not a caricature
or a disparaging image
like that plantation era mammy
that I was seeing
throughout history all
of a sudden here was a group
of white people from Kentucky
who had the same kind of passion
that Egerton and I both had
for these historic women.
And so, we approached the
University of Kentucky Press
and they agreed to republish
that book and facsimile
with a new introduction by me.
And that brought me to my second
time and visit here at the --
that brought me to my
visit here, my first visit
to the Library of Congress
in the late 1990's.
I came here and dug
into the archives
to explore African-American
writings to try to understand
who in their right mind the
turn-of-the-century would've
written a book with a
title by a colored woman,
it didn't make much sense to me.
And so, I set out to understand
more about black cookbooks.
And while I was here
I encountered several
of the rare books, rare
African-American books
that are here in the collection
and then I was hooked,
like I mean like as
they say mainline,
I don't know should I say that.
I started telling people my
passion and people who traveled
around the country would
bring books back to me
when they were on vacation.
They would bring back little $2
pamphlets that they encountered
in secondhand stores and
books just started sort
of coming to me.
And I didn't really know how to
become a collector in earnest,
but the internet
changed my life.
The University of Alabama has
I think what is the largest
collection of African-American
cookbooks,
the William Lupton collection.
And this book, this collection
has some 450 books in it
and that number is comprised of
duplicates, multiple editions,
there are some in facsimile,
and there is a large number
of books there that are
community cookbooks right,
that I would never be able to
get in my local, in my area.
And so, I used that
book as a shop,
that list as a shopping list
and I started entering titles
of books into the
browser at bookfinder.com
and I just would wait
every now and then
for something to pop up.
One of the first books
that I was just determined
to have was a book from 1936,
it was called Eliza's Cookbook.
It's the yellow one, I was
desperate to have this book
because it was -- it's
called Eliza's Cookbook,
Favorite Recipes Compiled
by the Negro Culinary
Art Club of Los Angeles.
So, I'm from Los Angeles and
there I started to have an idea
of who my grandmother
was in print on the page.
She was a lovely woman
and she was talented
and she was intelligent
and she wasn't
at all this disparaging thing
that I had seen so often
on the pages of history and
I had to have this book.
Now keep in mind, I was a
stay-at-home mother taking my
kids back and forth to swimming
and I was doing this in secret.
My husband until I started this
tour had no idea how much I had
really been investing
in these books.
And so, I entered the
title on an eBay auction,
the book popped up for $1.
And I was exhilarated, but I
didn't know anything about eBay,
so I went next-door to talk to
my neighbor who was a fanatic
about eBay and she taught
me all of the secrets.
She taught me how to set
my clock to make sure
that the tick-tock timing
on my watch matched
their countdown clock.
She told me not to enter the
title, not to enter my interest
or my bid because then others
would know there was a value
to this book that
had shown up for $1.
And so, I waited until
the two-minute warning
that she gave me and then
and I had been watching
the number sort of tick up
and it was somewhere you know
in the couple hundred dollars.
I thought I can live with that
I'll call my mom something
like that.
And so, I typed in my bid
and then I closed my eyes
and pushed the button, you know
like he's going to kill me.
So, I entered $400 and
then you wait and it seems
like you're waiting forever.
But the note, the little
blinking notice came back
and said you've won
and I was so excited,
but I was also terrified
like I'm going to send $400
to a stranger that I don't
know and I have no way to know
if this book is authentic,
I don't know what condition,
you know I don't know anything.
But I was determined
to have a book
that put my grandmother
in this category.
I called the woman in
San Diego and apparently,
she had been cleaning out
her grandmother's attic
and found this book,
had no idea the value
and she was you know just
astounded at what she was
about to earn for this book.
And so, my life went
on like that for years.
I just kept entering
more and more titles
and every time something popped
up, it didn't matter they were
at that point not
very expensive,
so I was still paying very
small amounts for the books
and really no amount
of money mattered I had
to have these books.
And the longer that I collected
them the more that they started
to organize themselves as
one of the essayists wrote
into a social history that I was
able to tell a whole new story
for the women who had cooked in
America's kitchens, who had been
so badly disparaged in
history and all of a sudden,
I had the ability to break
what I started calling the
Jemima Code.
So, I went to publishers, I had
a literary agent, I had 25 years
in the food industry, so
I was pretty well known,
nobody would buy this book.
I proposed it as a
beautiful coffee table book
that would have photographs
of all of the women inside.
I wanted everyone to fall in
love with them just in the way
that I did and nobody cared.
So, I found myself in
the same predicament
that my ancestors
had been in and many
of these books were
self-published.
Some of them are pamphlets,
some of them were even published
by manufacturers who
were trying to get people
to buy more of their products.
Some of them were books
published by universities
on behalf of the cook who had
been feeding the athletic team.
There was a food editor who
worked for Ebony Magazine
and she was asked by Carnation
to produce a recipe collection
on their behalf using recipes,
Carnation recipes in the 1940's.
And so, as I went along I just
kept collecting and trying
to convince a literary agent or
a publisher to buy this book.
And in my frustration even
though I am a journalist I
decided to just take the
project to the internet,
the place where I had really --
that had saved the collection,
I wanted to take the
books back there.
And so, I started a blog
reluctantly and I was going
to tell the story of every one
of these authors and so I wrote
that this would be
a one-year project
and if people received
them the way
that I did then I'd
keep going with it.
And I really just abandoned the
idea of publishing this book.
And then the University of
Texas encountered the website
and they came to me and
said we want to publish
that book under one condition.
And I said sure what
and they said we want it
to be a beautiful
coffee table book.
I thought I was going to die.
Really, this is what
they envisioned,
they wanted a book about books.
They wanted, they understood
my passion and my desire
to really change
the representation,
to change the written history
of African-American women
who had worked in this country.
And we knew that if we started
with recipes people
wouldn't get it yet,
people would think
all kinds of things.
So, we knew that we
just had to validate
that the women even
existed first.
And there are books in this
collection that are co-authored
by black-and-white women as
you can see here, this book is
from the 80's, Viola's
Favorite Recipes.
There are books that have
incredible illustrations inside
of them.
If you can see Ma Chance's book
on Caribbean French cooking.
There are others like her
who give us very detailed
illustration of how
to chop a certain dish
or how this guy in 1970,
1972 this is a diet book
published for African-American,
for people in general and he
gives four weeks' worth of menus
and does things that
we think about already,
like telling you how much
is a serving size of pasta
for example on this page.
And so, what this book started
to do was really
reveal an intelligence
that hadn't ever been associated
with African-American
cooks before.
We had previously been either
acknowledged as great cooks
because we came by that
knowledge naturally
with some kind of
a natural instinct.
Some authors in the 20's
even described as having sort
of a voodoo magic that we
cooked with, it's very insulting
and complimentary at
the same time right.
Again, that's the messaging
of a code that it speaks
to us all very differently.
And so, it became evident that
there was an intelligence here
and there was also a social arc.
So, I've been able to divide
my content now by generations
of women and I've been able
to extract characteristics
and values that have not
been identified before.
For example, in 1827 the
oldest book in the collection,
I won't go through them all,
but I do like to just wrap
up with the 19th
century authors.
In 1827, Robert Roberts wrote
The House Servant's Directory.
He was the butler in
the governor's mansion
in Massachusetts
and he writes a book
that is essentially
a training manual
for future generations
of workers.
History would have portrayed
this book as just another way
to create more servants.
It would have continued
to disparage the idea
that African-Americans
had any knowledge,
but this is a love letter.
The way that he has written to
his charges about their work is
so profoundly intimate
and smart.
He speaks to them about
punctuality and proper dress
and decorum on the job.
He even talks to them about
keeping your feet clean,
which I thought was
really interesting.
I have a really great story
about collecting right.
So, this book, this was a book
about women as the title implies
because there is a history
associated with men,
Thomas Jefferson had a black
chef that he had trained
in France as did George
Washington, so there are stories
about black men, but there are
no stories about black women.
And so, I wasn't really
looking for Robert Roberts,
but I was in New York City
and I called a book dealer
and I said hey, I'm here do
you have anything you know
that maybe I don't have and she
said everybody knows you have
everything already.
And I said well there's a couple
of first editions I'm looking
for and so she said
well okay what
and so I told her
I wanted this one
and she said call me
back in 10 minutes.
So, I called her
back in 10 minutes
and she said can
you come over here
in the village they're
bringing you the book.
Like what do you mean
they're bringing me the book
and so she said just come
over here they're
bringing you the book.
So, a disheveled guy who
was like obviously working
in this man's home
came in the store
with a crumpled grocery bag
in his hand and he handed it
to Bonnie and Bonnie handed
it to me and we opened it
and this book in first
edition from 1827 was inside
of that bag and I collapsed.
I had an immediate connection
to these people in a way
that I haven't been
able to explain
to any other audience right.
Everyone else just
thinks oh yeah,
you did a great job,
you changed history.
You know there's something
very unique and special
about the intimate relationship
between a collector who is
in pursuit of their passion
for whatever that reason,
whether it's a social history
that you want to change
or whether it's just for your
own incredible knowledge.
So, I will tell you about
two more, maybe three,
I have four minutes, I can
do it in three minutes.
So, this one, this is my
first holding of this one
and I'm shivering up here if
you can't see it and I have been
for the last hour since
Mark gave it to me.
This lovely little book is
from 1848 and was published
by this man Tunis Campbell
and among his accolades,
he's responsible for the drill
that you have experienced
at hotels and banquet service
when the waitstaff is all
located kind of around the room
and then they wait until
the exact right moment
and they march out and they
remove the cover of the dish.
He's part of why we do that, it
was actually a military drill
that he incorporated
in his hotel service.
And so, I use little
stories like that to try
to encourage the next generation
of young people that there are
so many incredible
opportunities in the food world
that don't have to do with
food service or cooking
or being a chef, that
there is lots of other ways
that we can uplift young people
from poverty using
the food industry.
This is a really wonderful
book, the only copy of this book
that we know of is
in the archives
at the University of Michigan.
This is the first
known cookbook,
the other two were
hotel manager books,
but this is the first
recipe collection from 1866.
And what is compelling
about this book
and what I tell young people
is that this was a free woman
of color who had to, she
had a handicapped child,
she had been robbed twice
and she was using food
as a tool for her own uplift.
She started a catering company,
she had a boarding house.
And so, what I like to
tell people about her
and about the next women Abby
Fisher is that they were women
who were entrepreneurs
and we don't tend to think
of African-American women in
the kitchen as entrepreneurs,
but these are women
who used food
to achieve economic
independence right.
Abby Fisher was a woman who had
been enslaved in North Carolina
and she and her husband
relocated to San Francisco
where she operated,
they operated a pickles
and preserves company.
And that she won multiple
awards for her pickles
and so the white women in her
community, both of these women,
they rallied around these women
and they helped them get
their books published.
The first time I
actually saw this book was
at the Schlesinger Library and
I guess that's as good a place
as any to wrap up to say
that along the way I was using
my reporter skills to aggregate,
to understand, to
represent these people,
but I didn't quite
know about collecting.
And I attended a seminar at
Radcliffe that taught me how
to read a cookbook without the
bias of race or gender and how
to look at the nuances of print
and paper and ink and choice
of color, and those
cute little squiggles
that I'm certain you guys know
exactly what the name of it is
that are on every page.
And I learned a lot about
collecting from that session.
So, I'll leave you
with where we started.
Lena Richard remember
her, the book that I took
out of the collection?
It turns out, I guess I should
memorize the page these books
are on, it turns out that
that little paperback
had been reproduced three
or four different times by Lena.
And the first time was 1939
and she published the book
by herself, it was a
self-published book,
she was an entrepreneur and
a restaurateur in New Orleans
and she had her own television
show before Julia Child did
in 1941.
So, Miss Lena published her
book in 1939 and James Beard,
the great father of American
cooking learned of her book
and he approached his
publisher and asked them
to reissue the book for
her, which they did in 1940.
And so, the book -- oh, that's
right it's not in 80's it's
in 30's, they did that for her,
only they changed the title.
So, the top book is the blue
book Lena Richard's book,
she calls it Lena Richard's
New Orleans Cookbook.
One year later the book
appears as New Orleans Cookbook
by Lena Richard and this
beautiful self-portrait
of her has been removed and
what appears on the backside
of this is the same mammy
disparaging image despite her
efforts to include a photograph
of herself in the view
that she thought she had.
So, I just want to
wrap up and say
that as collectors you have an
incredible opportunity not just
for all of your own interests,
but to really make a
difference socially.
So, thank you so
much for inviting me.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well Toni,
that was wonderful,
I had not heard her
speak about this before
and I think I could hard to
imagine a better introduction
to hearing other
stories from collectors.
When we first met tonight I
said I wanted to introduce her
as a collector, she said oh no,
no I'm an accidental collector
and I just kind of
backed off a little bit,
not knowing I said okay you tell
us about your collecting career
in the way that you
would like to and she did
and she did a terrific job.
Let's give her another
round of applause.
[ Applause ]
And now we move to
our newer collectors
and we actually are going
to award the prizes,
we're going to have Micaela
Beigel come up first,
Beigel I'm sorry, who is
our third prize winner
and she is going to talk
for just a few minutes
about her collection.
It's one that was mentioned
earlier, Once We Were Dreamers,
a Collection of Jewish
Resistance During the Holocaust.
Let's give her a hand
and we will hear from her
and then we will take a picture
with people from Goucher College
as soon as we've
heard from our winner.
Thank you.
>> Yes, thank you.
Hi, I'm Micaela, I'm a
sophomore at Goucher College,
which is about an
hour from here.
I didn't know I'd be speaking,
so I didn't prepare anything
so this is off-the-cuff,
but it's fine.
So, I grew up in a Zionist
Jewish youth movement called
Habonim Dror, which is one
of the first Zionist youth
movements that emerged
after the Jewish
enlightenment in Europe
which is called the Haskalah and
it was the move from orthodoxy
to secularism that occurred.
When Jews realized that
they didn't need to stay
in the shtetl and that they
could be something more
than that.
And famously Habonim Dror was
the movement that produced two
of the leaders of the
Warsaw ghetto uprising.
And two years ago, I went to
Poland with my youth movement
and we visited the site of
the Warsaw ghetto uprising,
one of the sites, the final
resting place so to say
and I felt very connected
with it.
So, all my life I felt like I'm
a Jewish person who's not very
observant but is very
connected spiritually
to Jewish history
and Jewish culture.
And you know that distinction
was hard for me to accept
because you know when you go
to Jewish day school they sort
of tell you that the way into
Judaism is through the Torah
and didn't I feel
that and this was it
and more specifically
it was Jewish women.
And Jewish women who were
artists and poets and thinkers
and who are more than
just Jewish women.
And you know that's where the
collection really started,
it started with some really
important Jewish women
and their names are
Hannah Szenes
who is an Israeli paratrooper
and poet and Zivia Lubetkin
who was the leader of the Warsaw
ghetto uprising and so many more
who tell these amazing stories
about Jewish resistance,
which is the idea that there
will be life after this.
And that is really what I wanted
to bring to the collection,
that there will be life for
Jewish people after this.
>> John Cole: Thank you.
We're going to take
our picture down here.
[ Applause ]
And I would like,
is your mother here?
Yes, please come up and join us
for the photo and presentation.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
And we're going to be joined
-- yes, the guests from Goucher
and also Ken is joining
us, this is the.
And so, I'm going
to be [inaudible],
let's do this right.
>> They want us over
here, sorry [inaudible].
>> John Cole: I'm going to
be presenting this to you.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Look at the camera.
All right, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Our second prize
winner is Megan Jones
from the University of Kansas.
Her collection is about the life
and times of Sacco and Vanzetti.
Megan. There you are.
[ Applause ]
You have some people here that
you'd like to [inaudible].
>> Megan Jones: My
mother's here.
>> John Cole: Okay we'll
get her up for the picture.
>> Megan Jones: Hello.
First of all, thank you, this
is a really awesome opportunity
and I never would've thought
that I would be here
for this so thanks.
My collection is on Sacco and
Vanzetti and I got started
with this because -- well I
guess it really started for me
in high school because I saw a
picture of them in the corner
of my history textbook and I
asked my teacher in Oklahoma
who are they and he said,
oh they're not really
important don't worry about it.
And so, I didn't look them up,
but I remembered their name
and then a couple years later
I was at Indiana University
in Bloomington and I took a
class at the Lilly Library
on working with modern literary
archives and I saw their name
in the finding aid so I
requested the material.
And I was reading through their
letters and I was like these are
so cool, I wonder if
they've been published.
So, I found the 1928 edition
of the letters and said whoa,
these are not accurate at all.
And there were a
lot of omissions
and things were changed
and so I started trying
to learn everything
I could about them
and started buying
books about them.
So that's how that started
and then one book would lead
to another book which
would lead to another book.
But the most recent thing I've
got was John Dos Passos Facing
the Chair, which is
about both of them
from a professor emeritus
at the University of Kansas
where I attend now
who had passed away.
The executor of his estate
was giving away his books
and he had an entire
garage full of books
and they were just trying to get
rid of them and so I asked her
if she had this book and she
said no, it's not in here.
And then I got a phone call
two months later and she's
like oh here we have
it do you want it?
So, I met her at a coffee
shop and she gave it to me
and it was signed by the son
of the Sacco Vanzetti defense
committee to the professor.
So, it's kind of exciting
how these things happen and I
like hearing other
people's stories
so excited to hear what's next.
But thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> John Cole: I'd like to invite
Megan's mother up for the photo
and Pam and myself
and we'll do a repeat.
Let's go down here.
Are you going to
smile this time?
[ Giggling ]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: And I'm going to
invite Mark Dimunation to come
up to introduce Luke and have
a little bit of a conversation
about the first-place
book in the competition.
Mark.
>> Mark Dimunation: Thanks.
Luke, why don't you come on up.
We're just going to take
a moment or two to talk
about our first prize winner
in the extraordinary collection
of an extraordinary individual
that's presented to us
in an essay that's
called the Collection
of Eugene Walter,
King of the Monkeys.
Luke Kelly is from
Harvard University.
The inspiration behind this
collection as we're told
in the essay was walking down
the streets of Mobile, Alabama.
This is a Minnesota
boy it is Mobile right.
>> Luke Kelly: Mobile.
>> Mark Dimunation:
Mobile, see there you go.
Alabama in 2015 where he
passed a sign that reads
down in Mobile they're all
crazy with Eugene Walter
as the author of this phrase.
It prompts young Mr. Kelly
to begin to investigate
who exactly this Eugene
Walter is and I have
to say it's a rather crazy
ride from that point on.
This is a very spirited essay
in a very spirited collection
in part because the untidy
pilgrim that we read about seems
to be one of those zeligs that
pops up in moments in history
and then disappears and
suddenly, is in the movie 8 1/2
and then suddenly
is in Hollywood
and suddenly is writing
southern cookbooks,
suddenly is in New Orleans,
suddenly is with
Peggy Guggenheim.
It's an amazing story with an
amazing variety of materials
that document this
person's life.
So, I'm going to put Luke on the
spot first to congratulate you.
>> Luke Kelly: Thank you.
>> Mark Dimunation: And then
to have you come to the mic
and I want to just
-- come on over.
I just want to have an
impression from you of what it's
like to sort of watch this
person's life unravel in front
of you and what you've gained
from that experience
while collecting.
>> Luke Kelly: So, first of all,
thank you so much for being here
and thank you so much for the
prize, it really is wonderful.
Eugene is not somebody that
I even knew about growing
up next-door to Mobile, Alabama
in Pascagoula, Mississippi,
I lived my whole life there
and I never heard about him.
But as I read his Untidy Pilgrim
it's kind of autobiographical
in some ways and collecting his
books, going through his poetry
and discovering more about
him and reading about people
who knew him and his life
there's many layers to it.
And one thing that's constant
through all of them is he liked
to have a good time and have
a party wherever he was.
And so, that's how he was
mainly known by people
like Andy Warhol lived
down the hall from him
and he called him Baby
Andrew wand they staged
like the first happening
at NOMA.
And one of the things
I discovered
about him along the way
is that sometimes he liked
to include jokes and little
hidden messages throughout his
work so he wrote under a
pseudonym called Sebastian
Willoughby and so that
was a challenge in itself
because no one really had gone
through and done a collection
or looked and tried
to find every work
where that was included.
And so, I went and I
tried to find every book
that was illustrated by some
random person named Sebastian
Willoughby and I would buy
the book and it would come
in the mail and it would
be him or it wouldn't be.
And so, I came across
some really great finds
of his along the way.
And it's still growing,
I'm still discovering
different things,
but I thoroughly enjoyed it
and I really wish I could
have met him in person.
>> Mark Dimunation: He
seems like a great mystery
and a great deal of fun
and I love the Andy Warhol
story I have to confess.
What do you think is the
most unusual object you have
in this collection or perhaps
one that was hardest to come by?
>> Luke Kelly: So, the hardest
to come by I didn't quite know
that I was going to come by it.
Like I said about the Sebastian
Willoughby there was this book
of these German, it's really
arcane and I don't have --
I confess I don't have a
clue as to how the history
of these poems came to be.
But there's this
translation of them
and Eugene did the
illustrations for them
under the name Sebastian
Willoughby.
So, I ordered the book online,
it came in and next to one
of the characters
on the cover of it
to his foot is a little
EW, it's like I have it
and then I opened it up and
it's signed from Eugene Walter,
but he doesn't sign it
Eugene Walter he signs it
Sebastian Willoughby.
And it's to his roommate when
he lived in Rome, he lived right
above Cleopatra where her
kitchen would have been
and his name was William Weaver
and he translated Thomas
Wolfe's poetry into prose,
no he did excuse me, the
Rose, I'm blanking the title.
>> Mark Dimunation:
The Tennessee Williams,
The Rose of Tennessee.
>> Luke Kelly: [Inaudible]
Echoes.
>> Mark Dimunation: Echoes
[inaudible] the Rose.
>> Luke Kelly: And so, it was
just a great, I didn't buy it
because of the inscription,
I actually had no idea
that it was there,
but when it came
in it was just a
terrific discovering
and it's probably my favorite
item in the collection I think.
>> Mark Dimunation: And so,
we'll close just if you could
to the audience because
I really do have
to confess it was a
cold read at the title
and I thought oh we're going to
be reading about some chronicler
of apes and chimpanzees
and I'm sure it's a very
good collection.
Could you tell us what the king
of the monkeys actually means?
>> Luke Kelly: So, Eugene his
favorite animal was the monkey.
When he went to the
natural history museum
in York he encountered
this monkey that looked
like he was wearing a tuxedo
and he just thought it
was the funniest thing.
And so, he would go
all the way and say --
all the time and when
he was in Paris and say,
oh darling you're the
queen of the monkeys.
And so, he was kind
of their king and kind
of just shepherded them
around and enjoyed life.
And so, it kind of embodies
his philosophy of life.
Monkeys do what they want,
they're very kind of boastful
and arrogant, but like
to have a good time
and that's the way he thought,
he was larger-than-life
in many ways and it
was just a joy to be
around for everyone
that knew him.
>> Mark Dimunation: Right.
Well thank you for a great read.
Congratulations, John is going
to give your certificate.
Let's give him a
round of applause.
[ Applause ]
>> Luke Kelly: Mr.
Goodman please.
>> John Cole: We're
going to move
to the right spot [inaudible].
Let's get everybody in front.
I'm going to be, well
I'll just be [inaudible].
Let's try -- just one more
I'm going to hide my papers
and I'm going to [inaudible].
Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
Well thank you all
for joining us,
it's been a wonderful
evening full of surprises
and I think we have
accomplished our purpose
of hearing the stories
that come out of books,
the joys of book collecting and
I invite you to keep your eye
on this contest, on the program
and to join us next year.
I'd like to conclude by once
again thanking the people who've
made it possible and mentioning
the Kislak Foundation,
which I forgot to
mention earlier.
Thank you and thank all of
you, please join us next-door
for a reception in honor of our
speaker and all of our winners.
It was a wonderful evening for
book collecting, thank you all
for your contributions.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit
us at LOC.gov.